what's up everybody
huge news we finally have the rating for
venom the rating is good news but I
think what's even better news is the
decision behind the rating given so in
this video we're going to be talking
about what this decision means for the
future spider verse with Sony
so venom will be rated pg-13 great news
for a lot of you younger viewers who are
worried that you weren't gonna be able
to watch it and for those of you who
really wanted it to be rated R because
you wanted to see venom biting off heads
and all of that good stuff don't worry
that's still gonna happen and the reason
behind it being pg-13 is actually a
really really good reason before I break
it down don't forget about the giveaway
I'm doing I am giving away a few copies
of Avengers infinity war on blu-ray if
you would like to enter all you have to
do is subscribe to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero
so venom is rated pg-13
here's what it boils down to Sony wants
to push the limits of pg-13 but they
don't want to cross the line I know a
lot of people we're looking forward to
it being rated art but here is why it's
a good thing that it's rated pg-13 and
not rated R the reason it's rated pg-13
and not rated art is because they want
spider-man to appear in future venom
movies The Avengers and not only that
and this is the huge part but Sony is
open to venom appearing in the MCU
loosening after you so do we need a plan
ok mr. clean is on his own page that's
insanely good news there are so many
different storylines that we could have
if venom appeared in the MCU venom has
taken over many people in the comics
he's taken over Groot he's taken over a
rocket he's taken over Captain Marvel
before this opens that all up to be a
possibility
Sony feels like if they give venom our
rating it pretty much closes the door
for any potential crossover with the MCU
so even though some people might be
bummed that it's pg-13 and not rated R
this is still great news
cuz venom could possibly enter the MCU
I'm personally okay with it because
spider-man beam in future venom films
and venom possibly entering the MCU is
just huge news
but what do you all think how do you
feel about this are you happy are you
bummed do you still think it's gonna be
a great movie are you excited for the
possibility of Tom Holland appearing in
future venom movies as spider-man and
venom entry into MCU let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and
another reminder about the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is subscribe to
my channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero thank
you so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
[Music]